hey 42 here most people see
dictatorships
as a thing of the past but to this day
2.6 billion people worldwide
are living under a dictatorship in fact
only 11 of the world's population
are living in a fully democratically
ruled country
the democracy index map shows the spread
and severity
of dictatorships worldwide the closer to
red
the more authoritarian the regime of
said country
but who are the 10 deadliest most
despicable dictators
of all time
up first we have the arse making
headlines around the world
bashar al-assad current president
and ruthless dictator of syria
when he first came into power in 2000
everyone thought he was a pretty decent
guy
promising hope and reform to the country
why would you think any different with a
family photo
like this but it all turned sour
very quickly when he ordered mass
crackdowns and military sieges on arab
spring protesters
leading to the syrian civil war since
then he has been responsible
for over a hundred and ten thousand
deaths
and he is now wanted by the united
nations
for crimes against humanity at number
nine is mengistu
hail mariam an ethiopian politician who
was the leader of the communist
dirk party that governed ethiopia from
to 1987. during his introductory
leadership speech
he announced death to the revolution and
to the ethiopian people's revolutionary
party
fearing people didn't quite get the
message
he threw three bottles filled with blood
from his pedestal yeah that ought to do
it
in total he was responsible for 1.5
million deaths and just to rub salt in
the wound
he even taxed families who requested the
return
of dead bodies of their loved ones at
number eight
is former north korea leader kim il-sung
up until his death in 1994 he led the
nation using extreme
force and deception he lost so much
respect from the people of north korea
that he decided to blame the us for the
nation's suffering
falsely claiming the american superpower
had launched a biological attack on the
people of north korea
causing a pandemic in the country and to
make it even more convincing
he killed 1.6 million of his own people
infamous cambodia communist leader
paul pott takes the number seven spot
he had a grand vision of a country where
everyone is
equal so he commanded all city workers
to relocate
and work on the farms and all farm
workers to work in the city
unsurprisingly this didn't work as
expected
so to punish his people he deprived him
of the right to education
medication and nutrition he also
executed 1.7 million people
who didn't follow his ideals at six is
ismail enva pasha ismail was the leader
of the 1908
young turk revolution and leader of the
turkish ruled ottoman
empire during the balkan wars and world
war one
but people soon discovered that he
wasn't very good at leading
armies after losing battle after battle
so to compensate for his losses and to
boost his ego a little
he decided to slaughter 1.5 million
armenians and over 1 million
other people of various races at number
is former japanese dictator hideki tojo
he was assigned the position of general
in the imperial japanese army
but he wasn't content with that so he
took it upon himself to assume the
positions of army minister
home minister foreign minister education
minister
and commerce minister oh and if
all that wasn't enough prime minister as
well
he also formed an alliance with the
nazis hoping he would rise to power
alongside hitler tojo was responsible
for 5 million deaths in total
at number 4 is leopold ii of belgium
he founded and ran the congo free state
an area of central africa from 1885 to
1908.
the colonial nations of europe handed
leopold the congo free state
so he could improve the lives of the
native inhabitants
but he instead used it entirely for his
own gain
he used a mercenary force to dictate the
native inhabitants
to collect ivory and rubber from the
plentiful natural environment
villagers were required to meet rubber
quotas
which if they didn't meet the
individual's hands were cut off
leopold earned a fortune through this
exploitation
he committed some of the worst
atrocities in history
and was responsible for enslaving and
killing 15 million congolese
number three is joseph stalin he became
leader of the soviet union
after lenin died in 1924.
stalin led the soviet union from 1922
to 1953. he enforced his socialist
ideals in an attempt to make the country
more progressive however stalin's new
socialist economy
led to the starvation of nearly 10
million
people many activists tried to contest
his leadership
so stalin launched a great purge
killing every person who opposed his
ideals
in total he was responsible for the
deaths of over 23 million people
number two needs no introduction
probably the most
infamous dictator of all time
is adolf hitler born in austria in 1889
he became a german politician and leader
of the nazi party
during the german presidential elections
of 1932
hitler used communism ideals and nazi
propaganda
to gain support for his campaign he
frequently denounced international
capitalism
and communism as being part of a jewish
conspiracy
after the nazi party was successfully
elected
he vowed to eliminate jews from germany
and establish a new world order to
counter
what he saw as the injustice of the
post-world war one
international order dominated by britain
and france
and we all know what happened next
during his 11-year dictatorship between
and 1945 he was responsible for
countless crimes against humanity under
the deaths of over 17 million
people including 6 million jews
and finally number one simply because of
the sheer
number of deaths is former communist
leader of china
mao zedong between 1945 and 1976
in total he was responsible for over 78
million
deaths this guy makes hitler look like a
schoolyard bully
mao had an unquenchable first for power
in his first five years of power he
indiscriminately
sentenced six million people to death
and during a very short period of four
years between 1958
and 1962 mao's communist policies
starved and worked to death over 45
million
chinese citizens many were also
beaten to death he also executed any
enemies of the state
at the drop of a hat thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42
you